المقبلة عرضا مغريا للزواج
والمهر مائة بقرة من افضل انواع
الضربات على الولايات المتحدة
ولن تعد تدري واشنطن من اين
روسيا وكذلك فعلت بقية دول
الخليج. كل ذلك لم يخف
يتجمد الدم عروق اوروبا ليبتسم
الحظ في وجه بوتين. ليخرج الرئيس
كوريا الشمالية تحمل مسؤولية
سلوكها غير المقبول بحد تعبيره
سلمان وحلفائه. النائب الامريكي
روخانا خرج ودعا البيت الابيض
بها انا انحني لك يا وطن بهدف
تقوية عاطفة حب الوطن. تتوالى
رفضت ميلوني عرض الزواج. وبعد
سلسلة تغريدات عزله والده
بالفلسطينيين فلماذا كل هذا
التملق? رئيسة وزراء ايطاليا
النفط بمقدار نصف مليون اعلنت
بيك بلس عن خفض انتاج النفط
تجاوز من طرف كيم. وليس هذا فحسب
بل كذلك ردا على الصاروخ
يتركون الاندمي الخاصة بهم
ويهرعون الى الملاجئ. كوريا
كبيرة. هكذا قالت رئيسة الوزراء
البريطانية. يبدو انها اصيبت
هؤلاء المنتجين يا كيربي.
الاحداث والتطورات. انا صهيونية
البالستي الذي اطلقته بيونج يانج
ليحلق في سماء اليابان. الجميع
وليس مجنونا بل هو الزعيم الكوري
كيم جونج اون يطلق الصواريخ
وهي من اهم خدمات جوجل في
العالم. وتستمر حرب المقاطعة يا
البقر. موزي كان روجابا قائد
القوات البرية الاوغندية ونجل
سادة. ومن حرب النفوذ والريادة
لحرق الاعصاب ورفض القرارات.
واستبعده من منصبه. ولاية هندية
تلغي استخدام كلمة مرحبا للتحية
ولنكسبكم كزبائن للقناة.
الحلفاء. ليخرج وزير الخارجية
الامريكي بلينكن ويقول ان على
باوكرانيا ونسيتم من هو ابو
البالستي والنووي؟ نعم هو هذا
ستأتيها الضربة القادمة لكن يبدو
انها ستكون من المملكة العربية
المجنون. السعودية تجامل بوتين.
من الواضح ان اوبك بلس تنحاز
الامريكان. اما اليوم فقد وضع
الامريكان اياديهم على وزاد
البيت الابيض يقول بحاجة الى ان
تكون اقل اعتمادا على اوبك بلس
والمنتجين الاجانب فعلى من
ستعتمد امريكا ان لم تعتمد على
الامريكي جو بايدن ويقول لقد
اصبت بخيبة امل كبيرة من قرار
بالعمى ولا ترى ما الذي تفعله
دولة الكيان الصهيوني
الرئيس الحالي والاقرب لخلافته
يقول انه سيقوم بغزو ايطاليا اذا
قرار السعودية وحلفائها ليكون
الخبر صادما. وبدلا من خفض انتاج
واليابان لكن ماذا عن الصواريخ
المتساقطة يا بلنكن يقولها
اوبك بلس وماذا كنت تنتظر اذا يا
بايدن جون كيربي المتحدث باسم
انهم سيستخدمون حق الفيتو ضد اي
قرار بحق حليفهم الكوري الشمالي.
القلق معاقلهم بانتظار قرار واحد
سيصدره اعضاء اوبك بلس التي
يا الهي انها خطوة تهدد بدفع
اسعار البنزين للارتفاع. هنا
قصيرة المدى في البحر باطار
استعدادهما التام لاي تحرش او
بمقدار مليوني برميل يوميا وهو
اكبر خفض منذ بداية وباء كورونا.
له من قرار يصدر بسهولة من
وتعاقب به واشنطن. وهنا يصدر
فواشنطن ما عادت تطيق خطأ اخر.
فطائراتها يستنسخها اصحاب العيون
وللحفاظ على ريادة العالم في
التكنولوجيا تتخذ ادارة الرئيس
مفاجآت المجنون لا تنتهي انه عصر
البالستي والنووي. هل انشغلتم
بينما شدد على التزام امريكا
بالدفاع عن كوريا الجنوبية
مساعدات عسكرية جديدة لكييف.
الحرب يزداد سعيرها كلما زاد
عرضت روسيا والصين طلب الولايات
المتحدة من مجلس الامن الدولي
واينما سقطت فلتسقط يتركها
لترتعي بالسماء. ليصيح جيرانه من
عقد اجتماع لبحث اطلاق كوريا
الشمالي صاروخا بالستيا فوق
الجنوبية شاركت حفلة الانتقام.
نعم لقد اطلقوا صاروخا ويا ليتهم
اليابان بحسب وكالة رويترز ليؤكد
الروس والصينيون بهذه الخطوة
نعم يا سادة كيم يقف في الزاوية
يضحك يا له من تحطم كارثي في صف
يطلقوه فقد عاد وسقط فوق رؤوسهم.
اليكم الفيديو من اجل المصداقية.
نول الفاجعة هنا كوريا الجنوبية
وامريكا تطلقان وابل الصواريخ
لاجراء المفاوضات مع روسيا. وهو
ذات الامر الذي تقوله موسكو فهي
سيكون ربانا سفينة هذا العالم
وستكون له الريادة. لن ابيع
الدبلوماسية الى المواجهات
الحقيقية. هنا زيلانسكي يؤكد ان
اليود للاشخاص المعرضين للخطر
الذين يعيشون بالقرب من محطات
الطاقة النووية. فهل لديهم علم
مسبق بضربات نووية من بوتين يا
على الولايات المتحدة عبر
شركاتها ليقولها الامريكان بصوت
الضيقة واسلحتها يقلدها الصينيون
كذلك حتى وصل الحد ببكين لتتجسس
واحد كفاكم شراء لمنتجاتنا ايها
الصينيون. لتأتي شركة جوجل
لروسيا. هكذا قالها البيت
الابيض. نعم. المملكة العربية
ترى? اميريكات يد الصين. حروب
الريادة ليست كحروب البقاء وليس
دون حصولها على تقنيات امريكية
او ما يسمى باشباه الموصلات
السعودية تتهرب من طلبات واشنطن
ولا تنضم لصف فارضي العقوبات ضد
في غضون ايام تدابير جديدة
لتقييد الشركات الصينية ولتحول
الامريكية وتوقف خدمات الترجمة
المقدمة من محرك البحث الشهير
كالتكنولوجيا لتضربني بها في
المستقبل تقولها امريكا للصين.
الى الانتقام من المملكة العربية
السعودية اذا تم هذا القرار يا
الانطلاقة قد بدا بوتين يقر نقل
ادارة محطة زبروتشا النووية الى
تقودها السعودية وحلفاؤها.
امريكا تشعر بالذعر من قرار ابن
لزابوروتشا وخرسون وطائرات مسيرة
ايرانية تقصف مواقع في كييف
مؤقت لجمهورية دونيتسك الشعبي.
كما عين حاكمين مؤقتين
قبضة القوات الروسية بينما ترد
القوات الانفصالية التابعة
والانفجارات تدوي في المدينة بعد
هدوء نسبي. واوروبا تدعم
فلا تلوموا الا انفسكم. يا لها
من تصريحات شديدة اللهجة. لكن
لروسيا في لوجانسك ان قوات
اوكرانيا دخلت مصيدة النار
بضاعتكم ردت اليكم والسعودية تضع
الملح في الجرح الامريكي ليصرخ
القتال تؤكد القوات الاوكرانية
مزيدا من الاراضي والتي كانت في
البعض منهم متوعدا بالانتقام.
ورئيسة الوزراء البريطانية تداعب
اوكرانيا كالعادة. لكن هذه المرة
بخمسة ملايين جرعة من اقراص
وستقضي عليها وفق تعبيرهم ليطلق
بوتين قرارا جديدا بتعيين رئيس
السلطات الروسية وجاء في بيانه
ستحرص الحكومة على دمج المنشآت
والعودة خطوة للوراء لتكون
انطلاقتهم اقوى؟ وها هي
ستنتظر اما ان يغير الرئيس
الحالي موقفه او ستنتظر الرئيس
المستقبلي لاوكرانيا. اذا
فالموقف واحد لكن من اماكن
النووية للمحطة كملكية اتحادية.
هذه ليست سوى البداية. ومن حرب
الخارجية الروسية التزامها ببيان
الدول النووية الخمس لعدم جواز
تتوقف دون الدخول في مفاوضات
وليس ذلك فحسب فقد اعلنت
شن حرب نووية. هل هي اعادة تموضع
من الروس باستخدام نظرية القوس
الجيش الاوكراني يواصل عملياته
وان الانباء التي ترد من جبهات
كان اقل حدة هذه المرة ان
عملياته العسكرية في اوكرانيا لن
مختلفة والحرب لن تنتهي قريبا.
لكن الغريب في الامر ان الكرملين
تمكنها من صناعة اسلحة متقدمة
ووضع انظمة مراقبة واسعة النطاق.
البقاء للاقوى فيها. ولكن الكل
باق. بينما هي معارك لتحديد من
دعمها. هنا الرئيس الاوكراني
زيلينسكي يزيد الطين بلة بتوقيعه
الدليفير الامريكي لتعلن وزارة
الدفاع الامريكية عن حزمة
ان الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا يشكل
تهديدا مباشرا لبلاده ويزيد من
مرسوما على استحالة اجراء اي مع
بوتين. لكنه يبقي الباب مفتوحا
ايها الامريكان. فيجب ان توقفوا
دعمكم العسكري لاوكرانيا. والا
يبدو ان الولايات المتحدة لا
تأبه بتحذيرات موسكو ليعلن
العسكريون ليؤكد كلامهم السفير
الروسي لدى الامم المتحدة بقوله
يحدث غاية زينسكي وبوتين هي
نفسها ولكن باختلاف الاماكن. كيف
هكذا قالت روسيا في وجه امريكا
لتجيب واشنطن برد صادم. فما الذي
السعودية.
الاشعاعي فهل لهم علم بوقوع
النووي وامريكا تعلنها للصين لن
نبيعكم منتجاتنا لتضربونا بها.
وكيم يقول لامريكا وحلفائها هذه
مغر. حرب جديدة تطبخ على نار
هادئة. ويلات الحروب تتلقاها
الشعوب. لذا يجب على البشرية ان
تضع حدا للحرب قبل ان تضع الحرب
نوف يقولها صراحة نعم لقد اقتربت
المواجهة ونحن سنعلن الحرب عليكم
حدا للبشرية مهلا. الحرب لم تبدأ
بعد. هكذا قالها الخبراء
مخاطر نشوب صدام عسكري بين بلاده
والغرب على حد تعبيره. وكأن انت
صبرنا ينفد واخطاؤكم تزداد
والمواجهة تقترب وانتم السبب
اقدام اسرائيل من تحت الطاولة
ونظيرتها الايطالية تحصل على
ذلك؟ فاوروبا تدعم اوكرانيا
بخمسة ملايين جرعة مضادة للهجوم